so when you see something say solve and
then there's an equation right what you
need to start picturing and this is why
we labored doing those graphs last week
for so long right I am this way you need
to labor see this this is a graph sine X
you need to visualize this in your head
and this guy's a graph as well right
let's see how I graphed six on there
where is half where is half on this
graph okay
well you know it don't you we said right
at the beginning we first drew each side
X okay but there's a top and a bottom
and sign X always a sustained there okay
it's always stuck between them what is
that what's that arrange what's the
lowest value can go by this one minus
one what's the highest rated one so
therefore I know where half is right har
should be halfway between zero and one
okay yeah it makes sense
great now on your fresh new sine curve I
want you to take your ruler and I want
you to draw just like I drew six okay y
equals six I want us to draw y equals
our half it's going to go through this
point
okay so this is the enormous idea right
when you solve this it's not just
playing around with numbers on a
calculator right it's say there's a
graph here this graph and this is
another graph tell me where they collide
tell me where they are equal where they
intercept their points of intersection
I've drawn them right you can see the
points of intersection okay now if you
draw your graph reasonably accurately
remember we expected x equals to a would
be an answer and your calculator told
you x equals 30 should be an answer
remember this subside graph is periodic
right it repeats so at this point I've
come back to the beginning how far
what's the size of my angle at this
point 360 very good so that's 360 then
halfway this point here should be 180
now you have a look at your graph and
see how well you've done it right this
apparently that value over there should
be 30 degrees does it roughly look about
1/6 the way right that's that's how
close it is right 30 degrees is a six of
180 degrees right minds you know bad
okay if it was a bit off no big deal it
will get better with practice
okay but immediately once you have your
graphic you see just like with the
quadratic right there is not just this
one solution
there's this guy hiding right here okay
so I'm going to draw our $1 line down
and I'm trying to find what is this
value this line here okay now maybe the
size of it jumps out at you okay which
is great but maybe it doesn't let me
walk you through how I'm going to find
the size of this angle okay remember
this graph it has all of these
symmetrical properties about it
in fact if I cover up this part over
here you can see that this part if I
draw a line down the middle is just a
mirror image of itself right so
therefore if I went 30 degrees this way
to get my first answer it makes sense to
think I should go 30 degrees this way to
get my second answer right and you told
me that that's 180 degrees and I've got
to come back 35 in a degrees you go back
30 and you land on 150 all right so now
you go to your calculator to test this
out you say well okay this is suggesting
to me that 30 is not the only answer 150
s also it ends up sine 150 and sure
enough it tells you it's a huh it better
tell you otherwise you can fire your
calculator okay
so therefore 30 Reis not the only a time
we should put up here as well or a
hundred and fifty degrees now maybe this
point you're thinking calculators right
how unreliable okay it's not fair
there's another answer why didn't you
just tell us that answer it could work
that calculators a smart I'll show you
why it doesn't tell you the other end
talk
it's very lazy though as it turns you
the first remember we set this graph it
actually keeps going we've only drawn a
portion of it right so over here on the
right hand side I could draw it some
more like this now once I've drawn it
further you see hold on a second there's
not two solutions there's four solutions
at least the more that are drawn and
then if you keep on picking like this
the four solutions there's gonna be six
and then eight and then ten in fact
there's an infinite number of solutions
yeah that's why your calculator kind of
panics and says ah I'll just give you
the first one okay and then you can work
out the rest there is a predictability
to it we worked out this second angle
from this one I
kappa third one as well remember it's
repeating every 360 degrees so that's 30
and I go forward 360 degrees they were
to expect to end up three ninety three
ninety three ninety sign three hundred
and ninety sure enough and I could keep
going if I wanted to so for this reason
that whenever you get something like
this there is not just one solution
they've not even just two there's an
infinite number okay when you get a
question like this you will see provided
to you in the question they will say
tell me just if X is acute what does it
cute me when it angles are cute what
what range are you from yeah from naught
to ninety not too many okay in which
case if they just want the acute angle
there it is okay
they might say give me a cute or obtuse
in which case you would say well this is
a cute and this one's obtuse so I
include both they might say something
like can you give me the answers from
naught to 360 that's that's this range
this range okay how many answers will
you find in here you generally will find
a pair just like this just like our
quadratic okay so this idea of solving
trig equations by thinking of a graph
and that's how you end up with more than
one solution okay this is one technique
I would argue it's the main technique
for how you solve these questions that
involve give you something like this
let's just quickly look at one a
together okay it starts off like this a
very similar way for the one I just
workshopped with you okay it says sine
theta equals zero point eight four okay
and for now remember we let these exact
values right 1/2 root 3 on to 102 etc is
zero point eight for one of our exact
values
now there's an easy way to test okay
remember how at this point right we said
oh I'll use my calculator I'll do sine
inverse of whatever number they're
interested in
right so for instance if I need a sine
inverse of this it can be better sorry
cos inverse it's a coincidence it's the
same cos inverse of this in handy back
at nicely 45 degrees if I did sine
inverse of this I can punch that in it
would hand me a nicely 60 degrees so I'm
gonna punch in sine inverse sine inverse
of 0.8 4 and I'm going to see what it
hands me right now when you go ahead and
do that shift sign you find it's not a
very pleasant is it right it just gives
you back some rubbish okay but that's
fine we can still work with it we're
just gonna have to approximate which in
fact the question asks us to do look at
the top it says correct to the nearest
degree it's kind of your clue you're
gonna get some extra stuff you're gonna
have to approximate away okay nearest
agreed so that looks to me like 57 okay
you happy with that
all right now therefore though 0.8 for
for sine we know we're expecting more
than one answer right it's not just the
first one that the calculator tells you
it gotta find another one find the other
one I went for any reason and then I
went 180 in a took away whatever I got
from the calculator I took away 30 so
therefore my next answer I should expect
will be 180 180 degrees take away that
angle so that's going to be 20 123 right
okay now you've still got that I hope
you still got in this way if you have it
just get it back by saying sine inverse
okay
I quickly calculate this 180 and I'm
just going to do 180 take away the units
on one and take away and it's up
there's my it's got it hasn't been
approximated on my calculator so it 122
point blah blah blah blah okay if that
answer is correct I should be able to do
sine of that angle and it's shrinking me
point eight four right if it's the right
answer so I'm gonna go sign its up and
sure enough it hands in back zero point
eight four okay
so that's how I quickly test these are
my two solutions right what I'd like you
to do is in this exercise till next week
I'd like you to do all the ones that
have side in them okay see all the ones
which have sine cos and tan work a
little bit differently and I will show
you that from the graph okay but we're
gonna have to wait till next week